Bill Clinton was incredible back in the
day the stories that you read about Bill
Clinton and the way that he would make
you feel like the only person in the
room even if you were just in a line of
people with whom he was shaking hands I
don't know if you've ever read any of
those no what were the principles that
people attested that to be so people
don't know they were just convinced that
he wanted to be their friend when he
shook their hand they knew that they had
a moment with him and that they were the
most important person there but from
what I can see it's that he's from the
south he's slow he's a little bit more
deliberate and he will spend more time
with people and also made it a point
every day to study people's names such
that if he shook your hand at the
beginning of a fundraiser and learned
two things about you he had trained his
memory at the end would say the two
things that you spoke about back to you
that is again extremely powerful takes
practice he literally would work on the
names of people apparently in the Oval
Office that he had met and refresh
himself on that kind of stuff